يعني هاي انظمه هاي انظمه بتخاف
بتخاف من المسقفينها لانه مصائفين بتخاف
من صحفيينها لانه بيكتبوا بتخاف
بتحط ايدها عميقات بتخاف من جيشها
بتخاف من جيشك تعمل له
تقليد قديم من ايام الثوره البلشفيه
بروسيا لنين جاب مفوضين سياسيين يوقفوا
فوق راس الضباط
النزيه
للجيش
صدام حسين عمل الحرس الجمهوري بايران
عاملين الحظر الثوري هذا نظام بيخاف من كل
شيء بخاف من كل شيء لشعور عميق بانه هو
غير شرعي مغتصب سلطه الشعب ومغتصب الشعب
هيدا النظام بيعمل الناس
اولا بصدقوا الاشاعات لانه ما بيعرفوا شو
السياسه بتسود الوشيه بالثقافه العامه
بيسود خوف الناس من بعض قله ثقتها ببعض
في كتاب كتير حلو
لامريكيه اسمها ليزا ويدين عن سوريا اسمه
غبوضات اذا بجوز نجمع غموض غموضات السيطره
تحكي كيف انه مثل ما بتذكر بعد كيف انه
الكلام بين السوريين بايام حافظ الاسد صار
قايم على فكره كما لو ان يعني بنحكي بنقول
مثلا حافظ الاسد بطل تحرير فلسطين كلنا
بنعرف انه هذا الحكي كذب بس كنا بنتصرف
كانه صح كما لو انه مزبوط
يعني هاي المجتمعاتنا بالاخر بتصير تحولها
المجتمعات مرضيه بالضبط هيك او مثل ما كان
عمك كتب عن العراق كتبوا الشهير جمهوريه
الخوف كيف العراق ايام صدام كان كله كذب
كله
فصام بالاخر القمر